[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhaenyra targaryen's son
aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
robert's rebellion also known as the war
of the usurper
was a rebellion against house targaryen
primarily instigated by eddard stark
john iran and robert baratheon
for whom it's named it lasted close to a
year
and resulted in the end of the targaryen
dynasty in the seven kingdoms
and the beginning of robert baratheon's
reign the most important battle during
this war
and the battle that ultimately
determined the outcome of robert's
rebellion was the battle of the trident
the battle was fought between rebel and
royal troops at the trident
across what would thereafter be known as
the ruby ford
a legendary duel between robert and
rhaegar was a fight which decided the
outcome of the entire battle
the battle was decided when robert and
rhaegar met in single combat
on horseback in the stream robert
eventually crushed rhaegar's chest
with a blow of his warhammer this battle
was the most important event during the
rebellion
as it decided the winner of the war
however all the circumstances and the
entire truth will not be
known until the final seasons of house
of the dragon end
what if there are some secrets we don't
know yet regarding this battle
as you may or may not know fire and
blood book on which the upcoming game of
thrones prequel is based on
is not entirely accurate as it's not
written by georgia or martin's point of
view
but rather george writes it from
maester's point of view who gathers his
info from other history books and
sources alike
also the only characters who saw reg are
false so only
the final blow what if robert did not
win a fight against rhaegar
or what if he did rehgar defeated him
what if prince rhaegar defeated robert
and told him to yield since he did not
want to kill him
gregor told him that liana loves him and
he loves her
robert yielded rhaegar helped robert get
up
and when rhaegar was not ready then he
put down his sword
at that moment robert smashed his
warhammer into prince rhaegar's chest
that's why robert was never happy he
knew lyanna loved rehgar and rhaegar did
not hurt her
robert knew rehgar was a better fighter
he defeated rhaegar only because rhaegar
was too noble and kind to finish him
so robert used the situation yielded and
killed him when he was not expecting it
that's why he drank himself to an early
grave trying to forget it all
i mean it's all there it's been in front
of us for years during his battle
against rhaegar robert was wounded
and after that battle he was never truly
happy some say it's because of lyanna
but the truth is robert never really
loved lyanna that much
as a matter of fact he slept with many
girls after his marriage was arranged to
lyanna
in this theory the truth why robert was
never happy again after the battle of
the trident is not only because his
betrothed
ran away with rhaegar out of love and
not against herville
but also because that same man lyanna
fell in love with
defeated him in a combat and spared his
life only for robert to kill him out of
anger
even though he healed it and rehgar was
not expecting it
so basically in this theory robert knew
lyanna loved rehgar and he loved her
robert also knew rhaegar was a better
fighter and he knows he would have been
dead if not for rhaegar's mercy
and that's why he's been drinking
himself to an early grave ever since
he could not accept it that's why robert
dreams of rehgar every night
and kills him in his dreams every night
over and over again
it hunts him that's one theory and
possibility
the other is that rhaegar was not even
there did not fight robert
and did not die there the story says
prince rhaegar met lord robert baratheon
in combat at the ford
during the battle of the trident where
the pair had a legendary duel
in the raging rivers of the trident
rhaegar despite wounding robert
was struck down with a massive blow from
robert's warhammer
which scattered rubies encrusted in
rhaegar's armor
under the water it's said that rubies
flew like drops of blood from the chest
of a dying prince
and he sank to his knees in the water
and with his last breath murmured a
woman's name
while rhaegar laid the dead in the
stream soldiers so both armies scrabbled
in the water to search for the rubies
later the location was named the ruby
ford
first let's point out the obvious it's
especially highlighted
that rhaegar wore his iconic knight
black plate armor with the three-headed
dragon of house targaryen
decorated in rubies on his breastplate
additionally the fort in which this
battle took place
is named for the rubies that were
knocked from prince rhaegar's
breastplate
now why is it so important for george rr
martin as well as for the showrunners to
make it very clear that rhaegar wore his
iconic armor that had rubies attached to
it
why so much focus on rhaegar's rubies
why is it such a big plot point and
subject brought up whenever the battle
of the trident or rhaegar are brought up
the first theory would be that robert
did not fight rhaegar
but rather someone else who had glamored
himself in the form of rhaegar using
rubies
as he was confirmed in the sixth season
of game of thrones
rubies can be used to glamor its owners
into a form or a person they want to be
melisandre uses it to hide her true form
of an extremely old woman
in the books mens raider glamoured to
appear as rattleshirt the other will be
in his risk of
the power in rubies is something called
glamour
where you can basically use them with
the power of the lord of light to
project a different
image of yourself if melisandre and
mance can use it it's most certainly not
after the realm of possibilities that
someone had glamoured himself
in the form of rengar using these same
rubies
and sacrificed his life for beloved
prince
the other theory that is also supported
says that someone else died instead of
rhaegar
varying his iconic armor remember that
in the books because he had been covered
from head to toe in armor dany did not
see his face in the vision
perhaps rhaegar never died on the
trident while the first theory says
it was someone who used rubies to glamor
himself in the form of rhaegar
the second one has less magic and it
states it was simply one of the
kingsguard members who fought robert
dressed up in rhaegar's full armor
throughout the books you have been given
a few major examples of an ordinary
fighter varying his hero's armor
to sacrifice his life for him and his
cause in a clash of kings
roger cassell attempted to put an end to
ramsey and his atrocities
rodrick's party comes across ramsay
during one of his hunting trips
but ramsay is able to survive by
switching clothes with his personal
servant
who is then killed in his place
basically ramsay gave him his clothes
and markings of identity
whereupon roger's men killed the servant
believing him to be ramsay
another example can be found in the
legendary last fight between robber
royce
the last of bronze kings and artist ring
the founder of house arena it says it
was dusk when artists and his handle
army finally appeared
but even in that fading light robber
royce did not fail to mark their leader
his silver armor and winged helm made
the falcon knight unmistakable
even from afar after the first six
charges
against robert's line failed artist
falcon-shaped helmet appeared in the
heat of the battle
robert charged him in the hope that the
andal army would dissolve if their
leader was killed
there we had two legendary heroes
meeting and fighting in a duel
except for a fact one of them was just
an ordinary knight
rover beheaded the falcon knight after
duel only to see
500 fresh handle knights charging at him
with the real falcon knight artist
terrain at their head
cunning even more than brute force
artists had clad one of his knights in
his own instinctive armor to distract
robar
afterward artists became king of the
mountain and the whale
and founded house serena those are two
examples of someone else wearing their
hero's iconic armor to sacrifice his
life for him
and his cons there's definitely a reason
why george r martin is giving us these
examples
there's also one detail from the popular
episode blackwater
that supports this theory when that
episode had come out
george r martin was pretty upset that
main characters like stannis and the
hound were not wearing their helmets
during the battle
at first glance it might seem strange
that george would complain about such a
small detail
but it actually makes perfect sense for
him to later reveal that rhaegar never
fought robert on the trident
a big deal would obviously be made about
one member of the kingsguard varying
rhaegar's armor and helm
but those are just theories and that's
all we have until game of thrones
prequel series house of the dragon comes
out
every question doubt or proof we are
looking for will be answered or
confirmed in 2022 on hbo
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace